chrissy teigen gets candid about  expanding her family with husband John  Legend I'm a lucky man we are here at my  Mary Claire cover shoot I'm so excited  for a ranch  here's Chrissy looking gorgeous in Gucci  on the cover of the magazine's July  wellness issue inside the model is  opening up about having more kids  revealing I would definitely adopt or  have foster children sheds I loved being  pregnant maybe I should be scared of  having PPD again but I don't know it  couldn't be any worse than it was  could it the 31 year old model and wife  has been real about her struggles with  postpartum depression after welcoming  the couple's one-year-old daughter Luna  we play everyday by ear basically we're  learning as we go and having fun